oh um game I'm not this short there's a
height discrepancy going on I'm I'm
quite tall actually okay hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to VR
kanojo now for the record I'm not
playing this game for you just because I
want to see something they say I'm not a
pervert I'm not playing that's not what
this game is about this game is a very
authentic faithful recreation about
being alone in a girl's room
with these hands with these bad boys
right here let's just start from the
beginning because I got nothing else to
do about this and I want to meet you
soon so do I so Louise so to me I do too
just as a perfectly professional
courtezan already sure I said the words
there yeah where am I in relation to you
guys yeah okay okay I'll go make some
who know I'm dude don't call me Mom
[Music]
hmm uh-huh okay now that's some sweets
okay all right I don't like sugar in my
teeth
maybe some honey ooh all right
again I'm behind the chair now I hi
knock knock knock how do i how do I move
how do I move these toasty bad boys here
need to know how to move look at ya oh
okay I looked at you real good
oh oh I'm in a cactus hi hello please
open up I guess I walk over a bomb on a
hip mine yeah oh I'm gonna hang on my
desk is hang on I got a ooh that's
outside of my range of motion lady
I think the scales a little off hope I
don't had nothing rabbit just like that
okay or not or not or not okay what
would oh I just got a look at it all
right well then I thought that hey
oh hello you're very tall and bouncy
you're welcome
did you just tell me to come on in when
I'm already in here no I'm good here I'm
good here here in the land of morality
where I'm not stopped Blanca okay all
right well let's just do that okay never
mind that are you trying to yell at me
I'm literally six to eight thousand feet
away from you the perspective is a
little off here listen baby we're gonna
have a standoff here and I'm gonna take
these toasted puppies and I'm gonna show
you what for if you think you can tell
me what to do okay I did it I would like
to reiterate that I'm just here for
study only if you think anything else is
gonna happen I'm gonna show you what for
I got a girlfriend
the first times a boy ever been in my
room kind of embarrassed about sterile
what do you what do you just what how do
i how do I can I don't understand I
don't even understand your language how
am I gonna be able to help you with a
book
please tell me uh no uh-uh no hold on
but no means no tall lady no means no
lady there's one big green book and
nothing okay I don't wanna I don't like
the I don't like these choices what does
the fan do with the fan oh oh sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry ma'am
I'm sorry oh what a startling experience
how horrible I might have psychic powers
lady giant giant lady lady I can't read
that what do I even call you what's your
name possession with the correct oh this
isn't even a language is so blurred
that's probably what it is
I'm gonna go with ya that's right
okay all right
whatever you say lady whatever you say
oh I don't like the way she looked at my
hand oh no no no oh no why are your legs
glowing
why is your crotch why are your arms
good why run away I want to run okay all
right Oh
oh good job buddy
sorry well done haha yeah me too buddy
there there well let's get back to
studying huh good pal so sorry sorry
sorry
what about one of these Bush no oh my
gosh she's immune follow my hand
follow my bit baboo baboo baboo does it
hurt when I do this
oh oh hello is anybody home
how are your cankles your cankles good
sugu time dated you're a quite beautiful
man fondle your bottom whom be cootie
sty indeed that's what they all called
me in high school
nope sorry all right I'm just doing this
for the sake of you know this has just
gotten a little too intimate here I'm
just here for a nice study session we
got a big exam coming up in a few days I
don't feel comfortable here all right
let's get back to studying sorry I
touched you so that has to mean you you
do what you gotta do I don't know what
kind of weird for all you're so tall
that's that's pretty Oh No okay all
right we don't need to see you that's a
little weird i'm visiting and you're
just gonna take it okay ah all right
well I'll just leave then ah nope okay
all right well this is um nope nope put
that over there okay all right that's
all so it's back all right hello friend
um can you just uh
how are your cankles are you trying you
sleeping no ma yeah that was my other
nickname how is your elbow you got to
take care of your joints um lower lumbar
doing all right
guchi guchi why are you jiggling when
you sleep also who sleeps like a corpse
like that lady lady lady good well done
get a nice pat on the shoulder there you
go that's good
go get him sport just where are you guys
we're can I explain this too all right
so this game is an educational
experience about Japanese culture we
learned what the capital of Japan was
probably okay all right you know what
go get them chimp go get them champ go
get them champ go get them champ go get
them champ go get them champ you got it
champ good well done okay good all right
how's them cankles all right good
cankles all right I'm out of here okay
thank you I wish I didn't do this I'm
not gonna be able to explain this one
away this one's getting be monetized in
record time this one was deem onside
before I even uploaded it fancy that
okay Oh nap time over okay you lit you
have a guest over you're just gonna fall
asleep Hey I came over to study we have
an exam in two days
Laney wake up was this even do house
them how them cankles that feel good on
your cankles look I'm just gonna clip
through your bed a little bit I got to
get the other cankle I'm very thorough
when it comes to cankle uh problem
solving
so go out Yama no indeed how's them
elbows you taking care of your joints
your shoulder all right just give it a
between friends or rather complete
strangers
all right does it hurt when I do this oh
okay all right hope we had a good nap
that was awfully nice for you not
necessarily for me I don't I don't
understand what's going on here am I
supposed to fall in love with this late
the lady okay you're still so you didn't
even sleep okay alright stret okay that
doesn't make any sense don't just don't
do whatever you're doing
just please don't how many sit-ups can
you do what in the world is this the
right time for this lady in what world
are we just oh it's set up a clock you
can't even do three leaving what kind of
person goes I'm sleepy Oh time for
sit-ups that doesn't make any sense at
all okay we don't need any of this we
don't need it what are you a baby nope
nope you know what we're gonna go with
the big old nope I worked out written
you didn't so it does so we didn't even
study we learned one thing you found
something nice time to eat I am NOT
where you think I am literally no one
eats like that lady the [__] is wrong
with you no I don't want any I don't
like this idea I get it
nope don't like this idea nope no no I'm
not coming to an inch closer to you lady
you know what I'm gonna leave you
hanging on this one I'm gonna let's go
no I'm gonna leave you hanging
sorry yeah no no thank you no no thank
you lady
you just shove it all inside your mouth
eating sweets made me thirsty I think
I'll have some water you don't need to
narrate your life to me what the [__] is
that about
as soon see how long she can chug this
water alright we're going for a world
record chug okay what why are you
looking under the desk I don't know cuz
it's not what I that's not what
no way alright you oh no you spilled
water on yourself
please do something was it's delightful
bog what is that what is that oh come
okay I'll go with the cup option I'll do
my best lady but so long as we can get
back to studying because I take my
education seriously as you obviously do
not cop bog okay goodbye bog okay looks
like it Randall it's your dead lady can
you please get some clothes on all right
well don't that's not it's one step what
the [__] yeah okay cover your shame lady
[Music]
okay turn that way
you got it lady you got I'm all about
this I believe in some I can't cross
here there we go
I believe in Band polite listen lady
we're just gonna get through this
together okay we're gonna get through
this we're gonna study we're gonna pass
this exam we're gonna continue on to
college everything's going to be great
why are you breathing in my ear like
that oh okay all right yeah okay I
thought oh all right then
excuse me while I turn away okay turning
Russell Russell I don't know okay nope
let's see looking away that's a lot of
zippers on a skirt you don't need to
breathe like that lady you really don't
sounds like a personal problem nothing I
need to worry about I've got my studies
if I had them could I help no let's go
with the big old nope can't do it I'm
sorry I can't no there's no human way I
could possibly do this I'm gonna leave
now let's this just leave I'm [__]
out of here I am [__] out of here come
closer what did I just do
all right well I guess I gotta come
closer oh boy
okay lady oh I'm closer now okay you are
so tall you are very what am i unhooking
can I feel it no I can't this is a
simulation I can't actually feel
anything in this game
what are you truck what are we doing
what are we doing it okay you know what
oh how them cankles your cankles good is
this the hook is the hook near your
cankles hull boop doop II Sorry Sorry
thought the hook was inside your anus
had to check there there good job champ
you are so tall you're you're a freaking
giant what are you six foot eight oh my
god okay unhook what am i unhooking I'm
really trying I'm giving it the scooping
motion let's trick that well that's not
right Mott's coochie i got you all right
if I comb it you know like a petting
fashion nope that's how isn't how is
that working I don't understand what
you're trying to get me to unhook what
am i doing what am I am i doing you're
just so [__] tall where's the
massager here we go let's really oh oh
wait hang on let's really stab this
India is this unhooking it is that
unhooking it is that that is that
unhooking it how'd your cankles your
cankles okay all right whatever then I'm
just gonna keep grabbing violently until
I get something what am i unhooking what
am i unhooking I'm leaving now okay
goodbye
I don't even understand what remotely I
was trying to do there it didn't work
and I feel worse for it
how are your cankles your cankles okay
okay you're welcome what the [__] are
you what what are you doing is it flop
like a fish time my heart why nope it's
getting hard to breathe what's it sounds
like we should go to the hospital Jesus
[Music]
okay nope nope no no no no I'm not
consenting this no I wanted to study my
concerns are my studies your cankles and
your joints oh you're so warm do not
touch me dude do not touch me I have a
girlfriend I'm fine please kiss it the
set of all right then I am uncomfortable
you feel so nervous hehe nope nope this
is hard pass hard pass on this one you
know where's my escape can I turn on the
fan welp Blanc Blanc Blanc um how's your
phone can i your bags [__] no no no no no
oh you perv oh now I'm a perv okay
oh well Oh God
if you eat fan is that good for you
sorry just trying to feed you your daily
dose of fan just shove this down your
it's like a Pocky
here you put this in your gob and oh
look mom it's like lady in the trap one
one one
oh god the slurping yeah I want to do
this again
no once was enough and that was with a
fan in the way okay all right then oh
all right well we did that the black
monster appears what the [__] is that
oh the bog oh okay
no can't do something you're left to
your fate okay well that was an
educational and enlightening experience
unlike anything I've ever seen before
I'm so glad that I went through that
what we learned was this is the first
game that's actually been able to
replicate my accurate height number two
I am uncomfortable in situations where I
am alone with women number three I am an
expert on the health of cankles and
joints so if you have any questions
about that ask me in the comments below
I'll answer as best I can thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]